let's say that you have a solution
that where the solvent is water
and the solute
is what we would consider drinking
alcohol
or ethanol so this is our solution right
over here and let's say that it is 10
percent
ethanol
which is drinking alcohol and let's say
the rest of it is
water
and what we want to do is figure out a
way that we can get something that has
15 or 20 or 30 ethanol how would we do
it
well the answer lies in the fact that
ethanol and water have different boiling
points for example the boiling point
of ethanol
is approximately
78 degrees celsius
while the boiling point
of water is 100 degrees celsius and so a
mixture of ethanol and water is going to
have a boiling point someplace in
between and so you could imagine we can
keep heating up this solution we're
going to go beyond the boiling point of
ethanol but before we get to the boiling
point of water this solution is going to
boil and when it's boiling because
ethanol has a lower boiling point the
vapor mixture is going to contain more
than 10 ethanol and if you could
condense that vapor you would then have
a solution with higher than 10 percent
ethanol and that is exactly what
distillation is all about
so you might distill with the
contraption that looks like this at
first it looks complicated but then when
you really understand what's going on
it's actually pretty straightforward
it's exactly what i just described so
what we would do is we would put the
original
solution
right over here
and then you would heat it up oftentimes
you're going to heat it up in an oil
bath that's what you see in this yellow
right over here because the oil won't
evaporate readily and it can distribute
the heat around in a nice even way
and then if you were to heat this up so
that the solution boils remember that's
going to be a boiling point someplace in
between 78 degrees celsius and 100
degrees celsius you're going to for sure
have some water molecules vaporizing but
at that temperature which is beyond
ethanol's boiling point you're for sure
going to have a higher proportion of
ethanol molecules vaporizing and then
they're going to be they're going to be
in vapor form and so they could enter
this chamber right here and what this
chamber is is essentially what's called
a condenser so oftentimes you're going
to have separate from the vapor but
you're going to make water cold water go
around this tube right over here
oftentimes a glass tube sometimes you
might chill it with cold air instead but
you have water coming in cold water and
it's going around the tube it's not
mixing with the actual air inside the
tube and then the water comes out of the
tube but what it does is it lowers the
temperature in that tube and so you can
imagine the vapor that comes in that
contains both ethanol and water but the
proportion of the vapor that is ethanol
is going to be higher than the
proportion in our original solution it's
going to condense back into liquid form
and then that stuff is just going to
pour back down into what you could call
this collection chamber right here and
the collection chamber is surrounded by
a very cold oftentimes ice bath so that
you minimize vaporization
depending on how well you do this maybe
this sample right over here might be
twenty percent ethanol or thirty percent
ethanol there will be still some water
that comes up here and condenses and
then comes back down
now if you wanted an even pure sample of
ethanol you could keep doing this you
could take what you collect here and
then heat that up to its boiling point
which will now be a little bit lower
than the first solution because it has a
higher proportion of ethanol and then
you would have the same process go over
and over again and so every time you do
that you would get a pure and pure
sample of ethanol
if you don't want to do that because
it's tiring it takes a lot of work and
actually you end up with a lot of lost
material through all of this mechanism
over here there's something you can do
called fractional
distillation and what fractional
distillation is is getting multiple
vaporization and condensation cycles all
at once so that you get a more pure
sample and the way that you get those
multiple vaporization and condensation
cycles is to give the vapor in this tube
right over here something to condense on
and that condensate some of it will
revaporize and some of it will drip back
down and the part that re-vaporizes is
likely to have a higher proportion of
the distillate of the thing that has the
lower boiling point and you can have
multiple cycles of this condensation and
re-vaporization inside this column and
so at the end you're more likely to have
a more pure sample of your distillate